okay looking forward to diving into the
audience questions segment on this
week's Friday show first one David can
you give examples of white identity
politics okay so I'm gonna answer this
one without any the question is so
succinct that this person's question
could be completely innocent it could be
a trolling question it could be a
rhetorical question I don't know it
doesn't matter so I'll just take it as
an opportunity to sort of give some
context and give some examples the
question needs context when we talk
about identity politics what we're
talking about is the idea of I guess we
could call them alliance platforms or
political alliances or platforms built
on identity groups often religious
groups racial groups social background
religion sexual orientation you could
have it you could have a military status
identity group whatever 90 percent of of
so-called identity alliances are
basically the realization that people's
identity is important and it can bring
unique perspectives which should be
listened to when thinking about politics
the other 10% is where it goes off the
rails and I've been critical of it when
it goes off the rails is where it starts
to become exclusive of people who are
not part of the identity group it
becomes destructive it becomes divisive
and toxic and I'm against it and I have
no hesitation to tell you that there is
a fraction of identity identity topics
in politics which become divisive and
toxic typically identity politics is
based around non agent identities so for
example if I say to you
gender historically men are the agent
identity and the sort of agenda setters
and when people talk about gender we
imagine oh this is a conversation about
women in race in the United States the
agent identity race is white and when we
say we need to have a conversation about
race in the United States people's minds
go to minority groups who think about
black people we think about brown people
sexual orientation the agent identity is
heterosexual cisgender individuals when
we say let's talk about sexual
orientation most of us understand it's a
conversation related
you gay lesbian bi etc so when we say
white identity politics we're talking
about identity politics around an age
and identity at least in the United
States exhibit a of that would be the
alt-right
which is effectively a white identity
movement and people will say well but
here's a black guy who's alright okay
doesn't matter as a general overview the
alt-right is a white identity movement
Exhibit B which has a lot of overlap
with the alt-right is white
ethno-nationalism type movements people
like Richard Spencer for example wacky
FoxNews guests who say white men are now
oppressed in the United States Trump's
campaign contained a ton of white
identity politics and you can see it in
that his positions that he would espouse
implied or sometimes even said that he
was going to protect middle-class white
people from brown immigrants coming over
the border to take their jobs maybe to
rape their women maybe to kill their
kids their children Brown immigrants
from the Middle East committing acts of
terror so on and so forth so it was a
sort of de facto white identity politics
and white identity politics in a sense
is sort of it's apocryphal in a
proverbial sense because white identity
is not under attack white people are not
oppressed there's no power structure or
structure of discrimination which would
lead us to say it's totally logical that
white people as an identity group would
be organizing to lobby for politicians
that will improve their circumstances
because they are the agent identity
group that is historically defined the
terms and controlled the situation's
the institutions of power better set
that being said the hypocrisy we point
out is that many of the people who slam
identity politics as a general umbrella
term participate in it themselves but
only with certain identities white being
one of those I'm ready for the comments
I know some people will not be pleased
with my analysis but that's the way I
see it and that's what the viewer asked